I'm looking over here I've got my little
retro pie set up and and I've got a
Mortal Kombat fight stick and I cannot
get it to map to mk2 and it's driving me
crazy because I want to play it so bad
hmm
why I'm gay too right now dear that's my
favorite that's the one that introduced
Barack I'm like it was such a big m'kay
fan I dumped a lot of quarters there was
a there was a bowling alley that we went
to whenever we would sneak out and we
just dumped enough like collagen stew in
tuition or in tuition tuition and
intuition into this machine and that mk2
came out and it was all these new
characters and the fact they brought out
you know smoke was there and reptile was
there you can actually play those
characters was super cool and then when
mk3 came out hmm there was a different
movie theater that we would go to just
to play that game and the Run button
just like changed everything on the
whole that was the first time since like
Virtua Fighter that like combos and
everything like Street Fighter a little
bit but it was mainly like the the combo
system and that was the first time for
me to ever be like holy [ __ ] if I timed
it that if I don't just button mash but
if I'm very skillful then I can actually
dominate Mortal Kombat to me has just
been like one of the most it was one of
those groundbreaking arcade games
because thinking back to where that game
started you didn't know about those
cheats unless you heard it anecdotally
that there wasn't any right there was
like a kid in the arcades it was like
watch what happens when I go up up high
punch when I play his scorpion and it
was like whoa he took off his face and
he burned the guy and you it became this
whole thing of like who can do this so
this it was this tribalistic kind of
thing that we just don't have anymore it
so to me it's it's one two and three out
of my favorite once it gets up to four
and everything else it's awesome and
fatalities are still fun and that that
time glad of that team continues to make
that and now they're bringing in
terminator and like yeah I was gonna ask
if you're if you if you because I when
MK 11 came out there was definitely on
HeLa and I spent many hours and and
hilariously she's so much better at it
than I am and I'm that doesn't surprise
me
I'm not bad but is hilarious Austin
because she's a woman why couldn't she
get
clearly clearly clear though just drop
all the rest of us that you're hiring
people to play these games to because I
mean obviously so no I think in her case
it's just she's very good at channeling
rage and and I'm not in weaponizing it
apparently - yeah she dominates severely
I think also she learns the combos and
remembers them to me I feel like I feel
like the confused version of that Zach
Galifianakis meme you know from the
hangover with yulymarie lows yeah
exactly yeah like I I'm the bewildered
version where I just yeah I can't retain
those for some reason really bad
fighting games growing up too but no
yeah I'm really bad at Mortal Kombat
because I got my start on Marvel vs.
Capcom so I'm very good at Marvel vs.
Capcom even though my favorite fighting
game probably ever is still Soul Calibur
- but let's see that's that's like to
see more more the reason why I never got
into console fighting games like I was
always parking um so and that goes back
to like Double Dragon like III wanted to
play that stand up beat him up side
scrollers were like my thing and so when
that translated to like being able to
move kind of you know like with Street
Fighter in the advent of a Mortal
Kombat's that that's that's really what
I but to me I want to be I want to be in
the arcade I want to be standing you
know stood up and actually add a a
cabinet for a fight game so that's why
I'm like super jazzed to get this thing
going because I can actually stand up
and play and I've got a proper like
Mortal Kombat I bought it off eBay
that's awesome it's beautiful yeah so
that's super off topic but I just wanted
to share one with me anyway to intro the
show we're not going to talk about the
matrix I will and you hear me better
okay
okay because I'm using a shitty mic okay
Audio Lissa's we had
oh I guess anyway we had like issues
what Troy was disappearing when one of
us was talking which has happened once
before so if that happens I'll have to
edit around it but you might notice some
of that but welcome everyone to another
episode play which listen I think we're
on episode 15 now that's exciting really
I think so I guess I have this I have 15
that's what I have locked in the team
seems right I'm a lot of PS I'm joined
by video game composer Austin wintry who
I said it before the show started but I
will say it now that we're recording I
finished ABS you last night and the
score is absolutely brilliant you did a
really good job that Austin it's
fantastic just kind loved it I was like
he's pretty good at what he does I
should start a podcast what I loved was
that you were like I'm halfway through
the game mild spoiler ahead and you're
like I'm having kind of a man night I'm
gonna play this very uplifting sort of
pregame and just dropped straight into
your best pal dying and ya know it's
literally where it loaded in was
immediately the the most aggressive part
of that entire game and then a character
I cared about dying where everything
previously had been white-hot happy yeah
whenever you were playing last I'm
amazed that you stopped like inches away
from that happening like that's them
that's even more hilarious to me now
that I think about it where I load it up
is is you come through a tunnel and it's
just this big really doc cabin I think
it's just out of chapter 3 maybe but
yeah I finished it last night
fantastic work shot at Austin retreat
we're also joined by Troy Baker our
resident matrix fan yeah dude why I
literally if I wanted to go back to
school that is what I would teach an
entire class on the matrix much to the
chagrin of the Wachowskis yeah man it
that's like I won't get into it but mmm
my crippled game director and this time
that's it just a marketing scheme to
make people by John wick eggs and it
seems like it's been walking because I
did get like a few messages about it
like I finally played it and I really
liked it well that's cool I'll have you
know that I think you know I was after
we did that panel I I did play that game
we did a fun house video there's a lot
of fun I specifically I don't know if
I've ever said this on the show I
specifically avoid watching any kind of
mates or people I likes reviews or
coverage of my games yeah cuz years ago
years and years and years ago like a
good friend of mine absolutely hated
that he was behind just put up a really
like and it's his job right like to be
clear like I want people to be able to
talk good of him to do that
in any case ya know like a testament to
how much how seriously he takes his
audience eccentric cetera et cetera but
like me watching is just like a bloke
who made the thing I was like genuinely
like kind of hurt and I had to like
process tango know you know so just as a
general since then I've actively so I
knew you did a video about it cuz I saw
it come up in the stream and I actively
avoid it because I just never want to
know how anyone likes it's just a comedy
video so we're just making groups the
whole time and trying to figure out the
gate I think we actually were very
positive in that video they're like
figuring out this is the first time we
played it was uh with Lawrence Sontag
who I love who has since left fun house
but he and I would I would say probably
the biggest like game is of that brand
so we would just go very into figuring
out how the systems of that game won
because it was not what I expected when
I started it's it's very interestingly
paced and you when you you're figuring
out like you know you watched us even in
that dumb comedy gameplay video figuring
out that well that action is going to be
completed by the time I do that action
and we didn't realize that from the jump
I don't know I just I do think that that
system was really it was really unique
I've not seen that in really anything
else you all make one of my stuff
speaking of today's topic actually I did
you do the music for now was it big yeah
but I let my normal ghostwriter
Gustavo take the credit but
angle is great for your biceps you look
so yes I'm for what it's worth my hands
are right next to my face
damn I heard this is the most I don't
know if this is the right color Audion
is it the right word well we're gonna
see where this goes what's what's the
proper word for someone who is
Coloradans I think I don't think there's
a word for that I think Carpathian
Colorado and hello sure that I know well
I decided to just embrace my Corona hair
you look like you could [ __ ] granola
that's what it looks just gotta honor my
roots like you were born with
Birkenstocks on that kind of thing wait
before we discuss my brief foray into
collaborations with Naughty Dog yes you
said something before we started
recording that I actually wanted to down
to just a brief second because when you
said you oh you don't cry at at films or
games but books because you feel like
you're leaving that world so yeah and so
I I that I was actually really
fascinated by that and I thought we
can't just have that as a passing
comment because because I have I have
felt super moved on from every medium I
feel like at one point you know song
like music you know albums TV shows
movies videogames like I have been
wrecked one time or another have not
been moved by anything I mean the start
of the Last of Us is a great example
it's just that a lot of fiction doesn't
make me cry but you made it sound like
books
instantly can yes so when I finish a
trilogy and pretty much everything I
read is always fantasy so I'm it's it's
usually a really long hero's journey
type thing with a lot of characters who
die along the way but when I finish a
fantasy series again like I said usually
on a plane I will solve even if the
ending is happy
because I feel like I am losing all of
those characters and that wealth that I
was so deeply engrossed in that I get
this betrayal and sadness it's like I'm
breaking up with that universe and
there's no more content and it really
upsets me is it because you feel like
there's not a continuation to that like
that the story has come to an end and
you can't revisit that even just in your
memories or is it because because it
done and I can't be with them anymore as
soon as it's over I could reread it but
I know what happens never extrapolate
like do you do you not just take that
and go do you like whimsically continue
their own narrative in your own mind and
kind of like create your own even if
it's just like mental fanfiction maybe I
should it might spare the therapy bills
that really the books are imposing on
you know I it's go ahead well I was just
for me I totally relate to that but
specifically in the case of Lord of the
Rings which we were talking before the
show I also finished reading Return of
the King while on a plane and was in the
same flight yeah she was I didn't I
don't remember if I actually full-on
cried but I remember I was so affected
and like again spoiler to those that
haven't read of half century old novel
or seen a half surgery quarter century
or more than that almost 100 years dude
that's not I thought it was like 40s it
was it's post was post words but it was
like yeah that's that's like 80 90 years
old he's like Peter Griffin my father
worked there 60 years that's almost 80
years but yeah you are so entrenched in
either Simpsons or family but there's a
lot of Simpsons references coming out
there David we're on the phone yesterday
talking and I heard like going it's like
that bestowed when the Ned Flanders I
was like
Coke's south parking the South's do you
understand that's true now that I
remember I finished the book and I it
was like I I was so where you were
describing it was so this goodbye
especially specifically the notion of
like off to Valinor it is death it is
the afterlife like all the heroes that
you cherish or the you know obviously
principally Frodo Gandalf like this
goodbye is so intense and powerful and I
remember and there was something so
beautiful about being on a plane and
just like looking at the world receding
and so I remember I just closed the book
and I just stared at the plane at the
window for like an hour and it was
really it actually was the perfect kind
of end to that moment for that reason
like I loved the goodbye I loved because
it was painful but that's why I loved it
you know I was so affected by like their
there's no more story to tell there's no
more yeah he did his job afterwards but
me like I'm saying before like the
Eragon series cuz I read that all when I
was a teenager and that last book was
one that took a long time to come out
because fantasy writers can't [ __ ]
finish their books so I was waiting for
it for a really long time I had it on
pre-order for several years and then it
came out and I finished it and I
remember not being totally satisfied
with the ending of the Eragon series or
the inheritance cycle as its called
but still again losing those characters
it genuinely feels like I made friends
that I had had for I don't know a decade
maybe and and then they were just gone
and I just wouldn't see him again and I
they were off doing whatever why doesn't
it but why doesn't a game bring that out
of you because all the same sort of
narrative mechanics would be going and
maybe even more immersively
probably because player agency makes me
feel like I'm doing it so it was my
journey you know even if I'm playing as
another character I'm the one who is in
control of what's happening there I am
NOT alongside watching super intimate
right reading like it's it's this
existing line yeah you're adding a lot
you're creating it's it's living in your
own hairdo in a way that I don't think
any other medium does and there's kind
of a there's kind of yeah you there's an
ownership
kind of involvement in that I say like a
creative process it's a it's it's hyper
interact and yeah hyper intimate yeah I
mean game Petraeus's can make me cry
which I understand is so dumb because
it's marketing but it was on IGN live
III when Beyond Good and Evil 2 was
announced and I was just solving on a
live stream because I'm so excited about
only three years it feels like that game
was announced 24 did you cry like to to
questions did you cry when they
similarly like when they now it's like
last Guardian was that did that hit you
in any way do it for me and that was
like okay so I have a thing where I cry
at e3 or whatever in a very different
way because it taps into this reminder
of just how [ __ ] much I love video
games so it's happened to me for ages so
I'll like watch an e3 press conference
and again I know it's marketing I know
these are billion-dollar corporations
who were just trying to sell me [ __ ] but
I'll watch a trailer and just not not
generally sob but just like tear up and
and be so enthusiastic and emotional
because I'm just like [ __ ] I love this
medium so much and I just get so
overwhelmed which is why I'm still doing
it I always thought that I know there
are a lot of people on the journalism
side who hate e3 and my thing has always
been the minute that I don't get excited
about III is the minute that I shouldn't
be in this profession anymore because
that would mean I push back against that
I think it's a very reductive way of
looking at trailers just saying they're
just marketing there's so much art that
goes into and especially with the Last
of Us of knowing how carefully I've been
using this phrase a lot carefully
curated each of those marketing beats
were yeah - that was part of the
narrative how we reveal the fact that
we're that we're answering the question
that people have been asking for the
last six years is there going to be
another one and boom that's the first
one and then boom who's going to be in
it and then boom everything about that
was so wonderfully paced
that I refused to look at that as like
as just marketing
it is there were people that were crying
I will never forget that walking in PSX
and as they're playing the trailer we
could finally come from behind because
they kept us hidden and we were able to
finally come out and walking through
people and them looking at the screen
and looking at but Ashley and I and I
sit down and us being able to be excited
and celebrate with them that's a that's
a that's art you know that's that's a
different it's like it is still
marketing and part of my job has always
been to cut through marketing has always
been to not try to get too caught up in
a trailer or whatever because that is
literally the only real service of the
journalists in the games industry is
like I don't really feel like we're out
here breaking important stories maybe
try a leak something sometimes I don't
even know if that should be happening
like that's a debate in my head is like
is it a service to leak information to
the public are we helping them or are we
just ruining the hype of the team like
that's a whole [ __ ] thing in itself
so the only thing I really can do to
help people is cut through marketing try
to understand where audiences are being
manipulated or mistreated or whatever
and try to tell them those things and
that's really hard to do so I have to
keep it in my head if like this is
intended to make me buy a product but I
totally agree that Studios was
incredibly hot on these releases like
that's where we can we can differentiate
I think it might be a little semantics
but I think we could differentiate
between marketing and like salesmanship
because to me the salesmanship is
everything you're saying that you have
to cut through it's the what shiny
objects can i dangled in front of you to
convince you to buy this thing
perhaps in in favor of showing you the
real thing which you may be less excited
by whereas to me marketing in its purest
sense of what that at least hopefully
ought to mean is no different than
anything else like we're here to
demonstrate that we think we've made
something of value and if you agree you
will part with your hard-earned dollars
to be able to experience it and like to
me there's nothing cynical it's the same
it's the same pushback I have when
people say oh it's just a job and I say
can we can we detach the conflation of
job to this like pejorative about that
that work is default bad and that you're
only just
in this extremely supremely lucky
position for work to not be bad it's
like that I I would love I would love to
have a more nuanced vocabulary for those
kinds of things
Chuck work work equals like I got a
drudgery like you automatically you know
but like to that point though jumping
into it I think you'll appreciate this a
lot of jumping into the the state of
play I don't look at what the what
Naughty Dog did with the state of play
especially contextually with everything
that happened leading up to it and
saying we hope you buy this game
everything even even Neal's tone
everything about that was we are we have
been working so hard and he made a point
of saying we appreciate your patience
and we hope that you're well right now
we know that this is where we're
releasing all of this in a really weird
time and we hope that you appreciate
this that you would that you we know
that we made this for you
so I don't I don't feel like it
everything in that state of play and
even show because like you guys have
wanted to see some gameplay let's show
you ten minutes of gameplay like let's
show you what this game experience is
going to look like yeah I don't think
that was like look they've already made
their pre-orders they've already gone
gold they've already shipped feel like
that that's a to play all the ghosts
Tsushima stay to play one made by
marketing teams is the truth and I think
that like maybe part of why I'm so like
listen I am someone who's telling you
that I cry at video game trailers they
still get me all the time in a way that
is like weird to people that I'll just
be like but at the same time part of my
degree was studying marketing and the
tricks of marketing and the effects of
marketing and you know marketing is a is
a cause for so many people's
insecurities they used to mark it on
utility they'd be like if you buy this
thing it will last you a year now they
mark it over flaws so they tell you your
hair's not shiny enough or long enough
or pretty enough cuz the marketing is
intended like in especially the beauty
industry it's really bad to make you
feel bad about yourself so that you
think that there's something wrong with
you so that you'll buy it I think we've
spoken about this before with Mike's
dandruff shout out to Mike stand right
you're the only one in the world that
Froggy's marketing tries to make you
feel that was the thing at the beginning
the intro like the mic thing that she
was looking for yeah it's great I love
it I love it I these conversations are
great mics hair looks really good yeah I
mean from my girlfriends are safe all
right
I think Troy was asking that as a
leading question to out you were you
between I will confess I did not I I
made the conscious choice to be as
virginal as possible with this one just
because now you're gonna hear us
describe it really important to tell you
Austin eye features music from hotline
Miami
I knew it does and it was the best
really does that's not a joke my
ghostwriter is gonna be my brain doesn't
even know what to do with this
information Neil Neil wuzzy yes actually
there's a character Austin who walks up
to the middle of the camera and says we
want add some music and they visibly go
through a pile of vine and they've got
they've got everything that they've got
absolute I've gotta log I may go no it's
actually it's actually Alana you're
describing let's play something he's a
lot it's a beautifully rendered CG along
every follicle of hair perfectly
rendered in the power PS ray-tracing
just by tracing the I will kind of
springboarding off on Austin I watched
everything up to game play and I was
like I can't I die I want to be I want
the first time that I actually see what
that may have seen it a little bit of
gameplay but I want to be exposed I want
to be like like Austin said I want to be
virginal to it as I can and everything
they talked about in the state of play I
feel like that that poses a unique
challenge for you get out your Niroula
your d neuralyzer no it is because i
mean this game specifically presented a
challenge not only just understanding
once I once I found out we're gonna do
this it's like okay this is a secret
that I'm gonna have to keep and then
everything else about that has been a
secret that I've had to keep and there's
it's it's no surprise obviously that you
play as Ellie so there's been a shift as
far as the focal point of my interest is
decaying there there was there's a story
that one day I'll be able to tell you
that happened at a at a table read but
you're not too far off but my kind of a
kind of the same way that I was with
left behind there's there's a similar
opportunity that I have to kind of like
I know this much and I know this much I
know this much but as far as this it's
kind of like I won't experience this and
even just just for clarity's sake even
part one I was like this so I did not
know what it was going to feel like what
it was going to look like I like the
Christmas Day feel of opening up that
present and being truly surprised so
when when it was like hey do you want to
come play like early play test or do you
want to see the grayscale I'm like no I
want to see this thing the way that it
was meant to I want to start from blank
canvas through final product because the
things that I make I love watching the
iteration but the things that other
people make I want to see you start from
ideation from the inception of that
thing to the culmination and completion
of it I don't I don't track that so does
that mean that you don't consider this
to be something you've made is that what
the implication there is no no any game
that I'm a part of I it was
I'm conceiving a game I'm writing a game
I'm building a game I'm a part of that
then I'm going to oversee every aspect
of it but when it's like I have a role
to play in this then I want to I've
walked out of it like I don't wanna see
it yeah I don't want to hear it have you
always been like that yeah I've all I
will close my eyes before I open a
present just to add one extra layer of I
love that anticipation so same thing
that's like I don't want to do with
indie games like often people offer me
like the chance to play something with
kind of things events I'm very carefully
so you know how I feel about books if
I'm saying that you know I feel like I'm
losing those characters or what I meant
is that do you have that same attachment
to games that you play a character in oh
sure like it was pot - you're gonna bomb
you out because it feels like a
departure for you potentially no it what
made me like in the wake of once it's
out like the same way with part one once
it was out now what becomes the art is
people's response to it and the beauty
of it is that the question of when I
asked Neal I remember specifically where
we are on stage of the stage when we
were shooting and I was like when we
discussed the ending of part one I was
like are you afraid that people are not
gonna love it and he says I don't care
people love it or hate it I just don't
want them to be in babblin and he goes
if we can get people to discuss this if
we can forget to start a conversation
then we will truly have done something
and when in June 13th is I want it
shipped I remember now that they were
there when it originally shipped it was
that that that we answered that question
people will and we have answered that
question every day subsequent to that is
that people still talk about this right
it still explodes talking about this
game this franchise yes
and it's and the beauty of it is not
that the Canon version of it is still
interpretable and people still are
wrestling with it and disagree and
that's the point of it as opposed to
well no you have to light the ending so
I wasn't bummed out about this at all
I missed Joel my eye and that's why I
asked you if you like when you finish a
book do you kind of consider do you go
and I do create this and extrapolate the
narrative beyond the text because I did
that I was like I want to know what he's
doing what he's feeling and I missed
being in that role is that at odds with
what they ended up doing for the record
I have not seen any spoilers I have no
idea what happens with what they ended
up doing in part two like is it weird
for you to be like how's Joel and then
you have to voice what I was written for
Joel it was it convenient you know
though there was Neil and I Neal and I
have had in our relationship on our
friendship we've had two arguments like
like - hey man are we gonna are we cool
right now and one happened on part one
and what happened on part two and he is
the most patient it's it's laughable to
me whenever I read some of the
disparaging comments that have just you
know splattered all over Reddit and
Twitter and everything else because it's
written from such a perspective of
ignorance that it's laughable because
you don't you anybody that says these
things about Neal and I know Neal's
flaws Neal knows Neal's flaws but the
ones that he is accused of are so
laughably inaccurate and erroneous but
they still can wound if allowed to both
both himself and it's like any I can say
any anything about you know my sister
but if you say a word about my sister I
love all [ __ ] come at you and it's
the same ways I felt this this feeling
of defensiveness for Neal and he he took
it in stride like I'm sure and we've
talked about this but he said his dark
moments because of the
but imagine this period of the the leaks
and everyone's sort of jumping to
conclusions about it there's been
extremely difficult for all of you like
I can't imagine that's been easy it's
the bear that the the weight that he is
born is for the team because what he has
to do every day not now has to do it
gets to do every day his walk through
that office and see the hundreds of
people that by choice willingly
passionately and lovingly choose to work
on this game because of the agency that
they feel in it that they have art that
they're making something good and they
won't quit until it's done and then to
see this be attempted to be undone by it
he he his heart broke for the team and
ironically there's a wonderful biblical
text that and for so many reasons the
conversation is gonna be laughably funny
but it's the same thing we're like
there's a there's a there's a passage in
whatever gospel where one of them one of
them you know Matt Martin Jesus looks
out over Jerusalem and he weeps for the
city because he just his heart was so
compassionate for the people and it's
the same thing where Neal's just like
man I just my heart is breaking for this
team right now if it was all on me I
could take it but the fact that these
people is that but for me there was
definite things that I was in conflict
of and and I go back to this story that
I've told countless times about Stanley
totally auskey talking on the set of or
talking about being on the set of
Groundhog Day where there was just this
massive core of contention because
everybody cared about their role and
there's part in the story including Bill
Murray which I always thought that Bill
Murray was kind of blase about it but he
actually had incredible care for that
story in that and that character and for
me it's the same thing whenever Neal and
I would butt heads about something it
was because he and I both understood
Joel on a on a atomic level and both of
us were wrestling with the decisions
that had to be made and I want that in a
director
and he wants that in an actor and we've
talked about the season I would much
rather have you then have someone that's
like just tell me where to stand what do
you want me to do he's like I can't do
it's it's like [ __ ] someone that just
lays there it's just like do something
do something yeah I was um what's a
conflict there's a couple things in
there that I am curious to sort of
unpack a little bit more because I
remember in my career that realization
of being part of the making of is gonna
wall me off from experiencing it as a
consumer and just saying that that at
first I was very resistant to that
because I thought no I I want to be able
to like this is a cool thing that we're
making I want to be able to experience
you know like when people message that
you know these these wonderful very kind
and often very moving comments about
journey every now and again someone to
be like you know you know what I'm
talking about and it's like actually
I've never once had the experience here
describing playing that game you know I
was at three years of weekly stand-up
meetings and discussing if this rock
should be here or there
like when I passed that rock I remember
that meeting and and at some point I
realize I you know as a kid I grew up as
is well-documented I I grew up obsessed
and remain so with Jerry Goldsmith and
yeah exactly exactly Goldsmith I
remember talking about in an interview
how he likes to be as he like almost
like a method composer he doesn't want
to read scripts he doesn't want to visit
sets or didn't you know past tense he's
no longer alive but he um he liked to
sit down and watch as close to a final
cut of the film as possible as if he you
know ideally with a bag of popcorn like
he said I want to try to be an audience
member and remember those feelings and
then compose those feelings that's what
he considered to be his job and as a kid
I read that and it's just this
assumption of okay that's gospel that's
how that's how you write music for film
or video games or whatever
and then the first time I experienced
what it's like to visit a set I
initially had this panic of this is
ruining it for me I see the director and
the actor over there arguing and I see
the I see the prop maker getting ready
that you know four inches away from that
they're prepping the next shot and from
my POV I see the movie and the next
scene of the movie all unfolding and I
had this window and I thought this is
gonna ruin my ability to kind of get in
there and be method in a lot a lot and
very quickly I realized I liked seeing
people do their job and be all these
little individual lieutenant badasses
you know and and really construct this
thing and and it made me more you know
as I got more involved in games learning
what the programmers are doing what's
the difference between you know the
different types of sort of engineers on
a project and what's what's a game
director versus a design director versus
the narrative director on a bigger title
or bla bla bla bla bla like you know
sorting out all those different minutiae
and realizing just how much sort of
specialization and and realizing if I
have to let go of playing it in earnest
but I get to see all this amazing stuff
that's so inspiring it's so much rather
identify as a developer doing the music
part then like this parachuting in
method composer who experiences it raw
and then bails out you know to keep
myself pure so it's interesting I've had
a similar thing in games meeting that's
been an ongoing conflict for me that
I've never figured out the answer to is
if I you know I visited I don't know 50
studios it's been a lot and I've seen a
lot of the behind the scenes of games
being made and I've always thought if I
see too much then am I not able to
adequately represent the mind of a
consumer when I review something because
objectivity and I just know too much so
I know more than they ever because that
anyone who plays video games or is
reading my review in order to purchase a
game will never have seen and won't have
an understanding of I feel like I
brought it up a bunch of how complicated
I know now lighting is in video games so
I feel like I pay a lot of attention to
lighting that's something that maybe I
shouldn't have learned because now in a
review I'm gonna put more weight on
where the light is then anyone who plays
that game will so it's this odd conflict
of like how much should I learn and at a
point
I have to cut it off so that I can still
actually review things for audiences
rather than reviewing them for people
like me which is a very small group of
people second austin i wanted to ask how
you feel about the way the joker was
composed it was i believe that she made
basically the entire score and then some
of the scenes were then adapted to her
music afterwards does that sound like a
nightmare
that's not a score no well that's a
whole can of worms with the tangent here
but I found that one really interesting
not ah or yeah you're just you're
indulging me very very graciously I
guess and generously as we're like so
Last of Us anyway Joker but I'll keep it
brief yes so Hildur good and a daughter
Oscar Grammy and Emmy winner within one
cycle first time ever and crazy enough
winning the Emmy for Chernobyl like
utterly a different project and it's
never happened before that like the
zeitgeist grabbing TV show and the
zeitgeist grabbing movie both Award
winners same composer unrelated
productions there's multiple layers of
first ever Sochi the the bathroom dance
scene and famously she wrote beforehand
and they played it back on set and
Joaquin Phoenix improvised the scene off
of her music okay and so it's not that
so you get into a fuzzy area Troy Purdie
that's not a score because I and I don't
know that I've fully decided where I
land here but to just lay the different
variables on the table the art of film
scoring just to keep it on movies but
this would equally trace to games I
think or TV or whatever the art of
scoring to me is the collaboration with
the filmmakers the other storytellers
whatever we're talking about or
experienced creators if we want to be
maximally brought here and crafting
something for their project you know or
for your collective project for our
project as it were and so whether that
means writing off of a script and then
iterate
or maybe just riding off a script say
your words on the page inspire this you
know hans zimmer famously did that with
Christopher Nolan on interstellar he
sent him a few pages of the script while
they were scoring and said I have a
father-daughter story how does that make
you feel and said almost nothing to Hans
about what the movie was acting was
about in terms of it like the science
science science fiction any of that it
was like here's a story about a guy
leaving behind his daughter in service
of her and what what does that make you
feel right music now and like so I
approve of the notion of different
directors experimenting famously another
oscar-winning score the social network
Fincher approached Nine Inch Nails is
Trent Reznor and Atticus Ross and said
basically here's my screenplay write a
bunch of it would not his it was um it
was um what's his name okay Sarika Aaron
Sorkin I started say west wing Aaron
Sorkin's screenplay and they wrote the
music off of that because I remember I
didn't know that until after I'd seen
the movie I remember watching and being
like wow this is effective I wonder why
they chose this for that scene and this
like the solo piano doing the over the
opening titles as you see young
Zuckerberg walking around the the campus
I remember thinking what a fascinating
choice and then I saw an interview with
them that kind of broke me where they
said Trent Reznor goes yeah actually we
were amazed that he we didn't think he
was gonna use that piece at all and not
only did he use it he put at the
beginning of the film and that really
shocked us and I was like you had no say
and you just you just threw music over
the fence and that blew my mind that I
thought I thought well okay that's
absolutely a valid creative exercise
like there's no-one should be able to
tell Fincher that's not how you do
scoring obviously it yielded an amazing
result and so it's taking away it's
taking away the the way that John
Williams the way the Steven Spielberg
john williams's like you're a creative
partner in this it's true yes Spielberg
would say Williams does a page one
rewrite of my screenplay
as soon as he gets the footage because I
you know that Spielberg's little line is
I can bring a tear to the eye but
Williams makes it fall it's true I mean
it's like it's that partnership you go
watch ET you go watch though you know
the best of the best of them together
you know Spielberg Spielberg crafts his
footage knowing it's incomplete until
Williams has it I mean who would guess
that one of the most exciting marriages
of cinema and music in history is
essentially b-roll of a helicopter
approaching the jungle like there's
nothing happening but Williams is like
I'm gonna I'm gonna deliver the ultimate
promise of what's about to happen for
the next 90 minutes musically and
Spielberg is like I'm just gonna tee you
up with beautiful footage of Costa Rica
basically and and kawaii - yeah I think
you'll go far really opportunities not
bad for a jazz pianist it's pretty yeah
for Henry Mancini's jazz pianist and
yeah it's so so all that said I I think
that the area that made me feel
conflicted about that way of working is
when you win awards for film scoring
when you when you basically made music
that the director then did all the film
scoring part of with so when Trent
Reznor Atticus Ross won the Oscar I
thought okay well at minimum Fincher
should be the third name on this Best
Score Oscar for making all the decisions
of where to place this music in the film
because that's how we experienced it and
with all due respect to Neil it's the
last of us Gustavo two-time Oscar winner
also works that way I remember after he
won for Brokeback Mountain he said I
only met Angley once before and and then
he basically discussed the film went and
wrote this music it did the job
beautifully and he won an Oscar and I
was at the time now of course he beat
John Williams score to Memoirs of a
Geisha which i think is kind of the lat
what well hopefully not but probably end
up being the final full blown
masterpiece of Williams on par with
his other you know Jurassic Park in
these others like genuine just perfect
piece of film music when Brokeback
Mountain won and then I realized he
didn't even score the film like he he
didn't he didn't derive this inspiration
from these images he just went and made
music like he always does and then it
ended up marrying very beautifully
Brinker to it I was like ah but the
thing is like you know Morricone
arguably one of the most overdue oscars
of all time was his Oscar for hateful
eight he does the same thing he reads
the script writes a bunch of music hands
it to Tarantino goes have fun I'm like I
don't know if that is film scoring isn't
that is that the same thing that was
like Scorsese getting his Oscar for the
depart it's like look this is almost you
know it says we're retro actively
subtext yeah the case of Marconi that
was at work like the in fact they had
already given him one he's the only
composer in Academy history or maybe it
was the second but I think it was the
first because it was the one of the only
honorary Oscars but a few years before I
think the Academy came to the conclusion
Marconi is never gonna win an Oscar for
what like they didn't see the hateful
eight coming they didn't predict that so
they gave him an honorary Oscar just
because he had no particular project
that year he so he actually has two
Oscars now because the first one was
like a long as like a punch card yeah it
was like we you're you're a legend if
ever there was one you ain't never did
genre yeah exactly so he came out to he
came out to the Oscars you know he
rarely comes to America he lives in Rome
and and it doesn't even speak English
and despite the family he's and this
made such an incredible influence on
American film and invented a whole genre
of music called the spaghetti western
but in any case all that aside yeah for
me the the the art of writing music to
picture or to game systems and to like
really getting in there that's what
minimum I could say this and then I'll
shut up I love I love that art I look
like working with Mike on John wick hex
and saying okay how does the game play
for the player they do this they do this
it moves it this kind of rhythm does
this music feel too fast let's put it in
the game and play it because the player
experience regardless of what pitch
decks show and concept art showed what
does it actually feel like to play this
game and how does this music relate to
that and really getting in there and
iterating and saying can we try this
exact same piece but just ten clicks
slower because and then and then play it
with that and see how does that feel and
to me that's so much the joy it's half
of the joy where the other half is the
actual like writing of the music which
obviously is the part that why I got
into this to begin with I still love
writing music but that collaboration and
learning what makes this thing tick or
watching those scenes with a filmmaker
and saying you know your choice to do a
close-up there even though it's just a
little dialogue scene but we're like
getting a close-up on their mouth that's
an interesting choice why did you do
that cuz that that I should change the
music I feel like I'm scoring the scene
as if you had done a normal two shot
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah you know
getting in there I can't relate at all
but all that said like just did Hildur
you know do a spectacular job like yeah
that and how you get to the finish line
creativity is hard enough there
shouldn't be rules to how we make film
so I would never in a way disparage I
just get a little weird about it when it
comes time to the awards which is like a
stupid thing to get hung up on because
it's so it's so superfluous like read
episode 2 or whatever of play watch
listen like it is so not the reason why
we're making it it's just the other
consideration when we're evaluating
what's the best of the best of the best
of this is the like are the are the
things that don't seem to qualify as
doing the job eligible for the award
because they're approaching it's such a
different way and I have people that
would say look you're so like you're
such a conservative that's how it's done
now you know that's the portal 1 versus
portal 2 argument one of those games is
the best game ever made it's probably
portal 2 but portal 2 only exists
because portal 1 does best game ever who
knows I can't pack it in both together
so I
portal even that portal - I think is
probably the better game Godfather - is
a better movie than Godfather one but
Godfather one is the classic but
Godfather two from just a film
standpoint as it is a better film that's
all subjective this is the one thing I
feel like Mike were just completely
relegating you to be silent for
indulging a diatribe there I'm really
I'm gonna always yeah that's the big a
pleasant from Austria
the thing that Alanna that I would push
back on were you like I can't know
anything because I have to experience
this as the player would is to me part
of the problem where a lot of this
teeing you up great Mike it is is part
of the problem that I think a lot of
game makers have which is assuming that
their audience isn't savvy assuming that
their audience doesn't understand
lighting that assuming the audience
doesn't understand a lot of the things
that we cram into things like a state of
play and going look at how we do this
and with the new power of the ps4 and
and and being able to the same reason
why when we showed the PS 5 they didn't
just talk about emotive things they
talked about the tech they talked about
the power everyone that talks about the
new PCs and and and and everything that
the Mac can do talks about the
processing power because the consumer is
very savvy and they want to know what
can this thing do they want to look
under the hood they want to understand
it they don't just want to experience it
and not understand why they're feeling
the way that they do so for you look you
are at that there's multiple tiers of
being a consumer you're like there's one
that I just picked up a controller I've
never understood how this thing works -
I'm super super savvy and you fall over
here but there you're still a consumer
you're just a very informed consumer but
to say that the consumer the the purest
idyllic consumer is not informed or as
kind of dumb is V definitely to say
what like the standard rule of
journalism is that everything needs to
be written as with the most
accessibility as possible so if I write
a review everyone should understand that
review even somebody who's never played
a video game before that is a general
rule especially when it comes to news
writing it just has to be as
understandable concise as possible so
everyone understands what you're saying
and and while you are writing the
Stanley rule right this is someone's
first coming yeah while video game
audiences at large are way more involved
in the technical side and the technical
understanding of that the creation of
that medium than a lot of other mediums
and I think that's awesome I also think
probably my biggest pet peeve with the
way the games journalism operates is
that so many games journalists write
things for their peers and not for the
audience so there's so many features
that go out that has clearly been
written for other journalists to see and
Pat them on the back with the thing
shoes rather than it being written for
the audience in mind so again it's a
really it's a complicated thing that I
think about back and forth all the time
it's like do I know too much about this
is this going to affect how I write this
but also is it an asset that I know a
lot about this and then I can inform
people on that side of it it's there's
no black and white with the way that
that functions but I have had thoughts
or I'm like if I know too much about how
this is made I'm going to give it way
more credit than someone who's just
picking up a controller and playing it
for the most part at large which is
where the accessibility thing comes in
that everyone should that's that's the
job of a good journalist is to take
something and distill all the
information down to being accessible but
not to reduce your knowledge like that
uh-uh
because if somebody has honored I don't
know how this works but just kind of
like this is this is what I know as
opposed to someone who goes I know
everything about this now my job is to
present this to you as objectively as
possible and distill all this
information down to a very accessible
form that to me is a skill just giving
an opinion has no skill especially it's
not an informed opinion so I I look at
you as someone who is a preview in a
review the review is just opinion it is
just supposed to be how do I like
everything where as a feature
or a preview can often be really
technical like my previews are really
fact-based I tend to not try to put a
lot of opinion into them they are very
much this is how this was made this is
who made this pot this is how this works
so they're entirely informative reviews
are just much meant to be opinion are
you saying that if you if you go into it
like let's say that you are reviewing a
game I'll just make up a hypothetical
but like let's say you are doing a game
where you got some inside look and
you're and you really empathize with you
saw their struggles you know halfway
through you realize that the combat
system was giving them loads of trouble
and then they had to kind of hack
together a solution because they sort of
ran out of time and you have all this
information that if you just got the
game we'd be like well that combat
system is is you know it's pretty weak
but you but you let's say you would know
the backstory why and you have a lot of
empathy for why what is your move there
I would write a feature I would refuse
to review it I would say someone else
reviews this game I write a feature with
this information because if I'm too
attached to something I can't review it
like I don't think I could review the
Last of Us because I'm too close to Tori
I think so you think so you think it's a
fair review to say their combat system
is super problematic even if you have a
powerful empathy like you think it's
worth taking them to task in a review
and there's no empathetic way to do that
to say look consumers be aware the
combat system doesn't work very well but
somehow packaging that in a way that
it's like it's not that they suck it's
that the idea would be the message in my
future sorry my go ahead yeah I was
gonna say there's some there's also
though there's the risk there that she's
making this she's laying them off the
hook may be unnecessarily right but she
may she may have empathy for how hard a
time they had but she might be wrong
right she might be know if they're gonna
enjoy the game but you can't say that
though that's that's the thing is it's
it's such a subjective soirée of opinion
and what you just landed on what we've
now kind of proven just what's the word
I'm looking for Austin empirically is
that you have attachment to it you find
empathy and therefore you are more
at more Eva precleared to be kind you've
you will be far less critical if you the
more removed you are from something
though the way easier it is to criticize
something but the more attached you are
to something then the less critical
you'll be of it that's the issue that
every journalist who's ever covered
charismatic politicians had read the
like we're always doomed to like people
and have opinions on the work they do
we are empathetic creatures that's
that's our whole purpose but the purpose
of journalism is not empathy necessarily
you can make it complete you could make
a compelling argument empathy has a role
in journalism I think that journalism is
about truth to power and in this
scenario power is the ultimate truth
though the ultimate truth is this is
that if 15 days for the ultimate truth
the ultimate truth [ __ ] camera grab
me right now I'm about to make a really
big fuzzy this computer is refusing me
audio is great done that's all that
matters the ultimate truth fuzzy picture
be damned best camera ever I'm not gonna
say who gave me this camera God is that
we can create this construct of
journalism that is set out to have this
intention but the reality is this the
underlying truth and we all know it is
that if we are attached to it we care
and if we care then we're kind period so
well the purpose of journalism is to be
this the purpose of journalism is a
construct it is it is to to pretend
portend that there is this objectable
ejectable objective truth that exists
outside of opinion but we're all walking
around as walking
opinions so to me it's it's I I I'm not
in any way disparaging a lot of what you
do I just I do want to at least be able
to admit that while we like to go based
upon this construct and that from from a
that there are these things we've set in
place that this equals good and this
equals bad and this is where this falls
on this scale the truth is is that if
you play it if you watch it if you read
it if you if you hear it you are
instantly one layer in to be able to go
okay now I understand it and you go do
you know that that person who wrote that
that did that that's that did was
missing an appendage like well Shh
there's there's a singer named melody
guard oh and I liked her music it was
okay would come on through the Spotify
or whatever god damn it he stopped
speaking voice was good it was it was
like it's you know she's got a very cool
voice I've heard it before and then I
found out that she uh there's a couple
songs that she doesn't French I'm like
alright so she's probably Canadian and
she's a francophone and she can go back
and forth between English and French not
uncommon nope girl was grew up poor in
Jersey and she plays piano she plays
guitar and in all of her pictures she
wears these tinted sunglasses I'm like
she's trying to be cool nope
six years ago I think it was she was in
a car accident that left her in she was
bedridden in traction for I think ten
months and she not only had to relearn
how to play piano how to play guitar she
had to relearn how to walk and how to
speak so every note that that woman
sings now in English or French every
note she plays on the piano I now
understand came through nothing but
sheer determination diligence and will
and that makes her music and her one of
my most favorite artists ever but if I
was
to go on a scale of one to ten from
singers she's a six because that she can
can't hit this C above high C or
whatever that that's that's a stupid
thing it's all subjective and that's why
those facts can coexist yeah you can
have you can have the absolute respect
and love for someone for going through
what you're describing and also be like
but honestly I thought the songs kind of
sucks
and those two truths could be
simultaneously true right so you can
have yes you can you qualify that by
saying but honestly in all truth I think
it sucks but that doesn't mean that it
sucks no and I do also want to say no
the pointy journalism is absolutely
never never suggesting anything can be
objective like they teach you that in
university right it's journalism it's
the pursuit of object yes you're trying
it's hard to be objective as you can
yeah while acknowledging that it is
impossible because even when you're
writing a news article the triangle
method is what they say is if you're
you're writing news in theory you should
be able to cut if you need to cut you
should be able to cut from the bottom so
the most important information goes at
the top but even in that in in writing
which line is most important at the very
top that's human bias you are deciding
what line is the most important it is
pursuit above the objectivity while
acknowledging that it does not actually
exist so it is it is an attempt do you
feel that that's still prevalent and is
something that is that is because most
people present it as fact but there's
like for someone who went to school for
it who got a degree in this they're like
well we operate under that assumption
but do you think by and large that's
communicated by those people to the
public by journalists yeah like you take
a Jim sterling or whatever Jim sterling
is touting this is truth his opinion
he's touting is true I'm using that as
an extremely she'll and I'm sure Jim
what it would agree with him being an
extremely with Jim you've got layers of
performance as well that's a character
that's really sure think about what
happened what has happened to journalism
now is like journalism was invented
before the state they call it the whole
the whole purpose of journalism was to
exist outside of politics except exist
outside of church and outside of just
regular civilian families and to provide
truth on all of the other estate
but part of it was that the audience was
supposed to actively try very hard to
work with journalism to understand if
something says allegedly it is on the
audience to remember that it says
allegedly but we've kind of gotten to
this part and this was like a very big
talking point even while I was studying
journalism in university where people
seem to gloss over those words now so
the cohesion and the requirement for
journalism and the public to work
together is a little bit lost so you
could say our journalists presenting
things too much as fact that is
technically true but it is in in some
ways on the audience to read multiple
sources go to multiple websites and know
that something is written even in an
objective way unless it is sourced it is
not inherently fact and that that's a
pot where it's gotten really muddy and
really complicated and that's you know I
think a very interesting talking point
for journalism scholars is that the
audience is no longer working as hard as
they were always intended to there are
always supposed to be multiple outlets
with different political background
they're not acting they're not acting to
hold journalism accountable either
they're not they're not saying this
person is a person who maybe we don't
trust this person is abide by the
criteria of journalistic integrity so I
buy their set by how they're holding we
judge journalists often by whether they
agree with us rather not only that but
also I think by and large the narrative
right now is to vilify and I'm not doing
this but to vilify journalism to say
they're the fault it's the main
lamestream media and in fake news and
all of that to say but but what that is
actually doing like I did a lot I didn't
think about this is to say hey the
public has a role to play in this as
well
journalist it's a cycle though isn't it
like if you feed the beast for sure well
and then and then the beast accepts
being fed yeah that's the thing that I
see like you see you know those same
outlets that the the public is not doing
their part but the but the a given
outlet you know you think of like the
really sensational like Alex Jones types
or whatever they get such they get such
reinforced
for that behavior that they are
incentivize actively to to be as
over-the-top and major problems as
YouTube is a platform you're
incentivized to radicalize because
people will click on radical things but
you keep doing it Twitter is the same we
could get in that whole thing is that's
super relevant right now as far as
should Twitter have happy getting
involved in all of this when they have
clearly said that they are they are a
platform they're not a publisher I don't
know something's gonna happen I was like
you're gonna pretty much just up in the
First Amendment I mean what are you what
are you gonna do it doesn't even count
just social media it's complicated but
to bring this back to the laughs sorry
journalistically the loss of us is a
very interesting one when reviews come
out like I've been talking to friends
about it and we're like this game's
probably gonna get tens no matter what
in part it could absolutely not but it's
really complicated because we have
journalists who all have the knowledge
of nobody dog crunch that situation who
are obviously very disapproving of that
there's been controversy around some of
the topics in the game which I think the
journalists are largely defensive off
and then it's like a beautiful cinematic
masterpiece by the looks of things from
a studio that everyone really loves with
the story that everyone really loves
there's there is no way these reviews
can even come close to being objective
because there's so much surrounding this
game that they'll do that damn best but
it's it's going to be emotional no
matter what and I'm really interested in
it's like a slider car right like good
fight like finding a useful review of
the sniper true right because it's like
everyone has a stake needed to be the
best thing I don't know why I want that
I think I don't like it and that's not a
stance I should have but that means that
I shouldn't cover it that's the rule was
anyone in though I don't think there's
anyone in nerd culture who doesn't have
say this and and it may be best for me
to kind of bow out at this point but
over the last couple of days because
people certain people especially people
inside of Sony have been able to plating
the Last of Us
um my my inbox and I'm sure others as
well has been flooded with support
appreciation and affirmation that the
story that everyone at Naughty Dog was
trying to tell was told and it has been
incredibly impactful and it's it's been
that's even before the general public
and once it's available to everybody and
once that those things there will be
waves crashing crashing on both Shores
I'm prepared for that and again that was
never the point was for them to only
fall on one Shore sure it was for the
fact for there to be an ocean of
conversation between the two [ __ ]
interesting way more interesting so I I
welcome that but already what I'm seeing
is that there are waves the waters are
churning already and that's just over
the few people that have had a chance to
actually pick up the controller I will
say who's broken embargo that I know of
because sure I've had plenty of
conversations with people who played it
but I can't talk about them the only
person who's broken embargo said they
had seen all the leaks and that you
should absolutely not judge the entire
game based on those leaks and that there
is so much more context in game play if
you have absolutely not seen and than
anyone because you and they understand
the game is an idiot how could you how
could you not assume that having played
the first one yeah I mean is there even
even as even as powerful as multiple
singular moments are in that game no
single moment encapsulates the whole
game yeah because it's it's just it's so
rich it's so it's so deeply study of
humana the loss of us but then I would
miss that part where you walk in the
room and you discover the family where
one of them got infected and so I think
it's the father killed all of his kids
and left and not like and that is like
something that really is stuff like that
in the lost was stood out to me so so so
much some of my favorite moments in that
game are those kinds of things the the
so-called environmental storytelling
that's that was the game that made me
really perk up about the notion of
ambient
like I always loved that like in the
original Deus Ex I always loved reading
all the emails on the people's computers
because half of them
like hey you want to get drinks after
work and then the other half would be
like you know might like aliens ah yeah
exactly
I I have found something that I'm not
supposed to know about whatever canned
fish today and then the other ones like
the robots are taking oh yeah
The Last of Us even just when you walk
into a room and you just see like
footprints next to like a burned-out
candle or what you know I mean like even
just the the amount of narrative that go
that's one of those things that makes
games games that you just like yes of
course you can set dress and you can do
a lot of that and I love watching those
behind the scenes of Star Wars and Star
Trek and Avengers and you just see like
like that great one was in in the rise
of Skywalker John Williams cameo I don't
think we talked about that here did we
so John Williams has a cameo in the
movie is only on screen cameo I think of
his whole career and he certainly was
never in any of the other Star Wars he
was ball man or he's in the book he's
the bartender who was very disapproving
I shake his head like who are these
idiots and when they come in looking for
the sort of the sort of underworld guy
to fix c-3po he'd seen the movie yeah
and and so they so the thing that was so
cool was that
in honor of Williams because of just the
reverence around him and especially from
from JJ Abrams part who grew up like
obsessed with him and with Spielberg and
all that Williams the character that
they invented of him which I can't
remember the name but it's like an
anagram of maestro they he has all this
junk this like metal you know kind of
broken down looking Star Wars junk
around him and I watched a little
feature at where John Williams has has
51 I'm suddenly blanking Hart
blasphemously is 51 or 52 Oscar
nominations I know it has Austin now
well he has five Oscars but it's the
amount of nominations I mean you can
telepathically give what
I know exactly empirically I think it's
51 but I think yes so he has yes yes
we'll say 51 trinkets that they made
that represent those movies so it's like
there's a little metallic whip for in
Raiders of the Lost Ark there is the
spiky Beach to Orion
52 it was one of the did well this year
yeah so fifty two little pieces of stuff
representing each of those movies and
they were so creative in how they chose
to represent like jaws was the buoys
like that they used to try to that shark
manages to pull underwater as a
demonstration of force they used that to
demonstrate to represent jaws so there's
like little chrome buoys sitting next to
to Williams at his bar top and it's it's
so cool and I love so it's like there's
all this and that's obviously kind of
meta because it's not interior to Star
Wars but the point is or it's sort of
like fourth wall breaking but point is
the amount of storytelling that goes
into even just the props that barely are
seen in the frame that kind of stuff is
amazing in the Last of Us to me was like
it took that to an extreme where you
actually were rewarded for going into
that room that the best gameplay
justification is I find part of a thing
that I can craft into a lockpick later
but it's like I don't actually need that
I actually am moved just by going into
that really shiny collectible yeah it's
really not it's so yeah exactly the
whole point of that and that is what
this one person who technically Bert NDA
said is the [ __ ] that you've seen is not
even the point of this game and right
yeah I think like an eel even said that
himself and I'm sure you've touched on
that Troy it's like you missing so much
and the one thing that I actually like
did want to talk about for the two of us
who seen gameplay Mike is we won't spoil
it but I'm so impressed by the size of
the environments even in the combat
encounters that it looked like there are
a million ways to get into combat and
get out of it
whether it's like smashing through a
glass window or finding and running away
you have to push through running away
um the even the amount of weapon variety
like I was just very impressed by how
creative that seemed and and it reminded
me of if you guys have played lost
legacy how open some of those areas
where it was like it had an open walled
inside of the game occasionally and yeah
the gameplay that we saw very much felt
like that to me where I was like this
looks absolutely amazing and if every
piece of that has some lore in it like
I'm just absolutely down to get lost in
that it just looked huge like I'm bigger
than than anything Naughty Dog's made
before by the looks of things it's just
really pretty and sound design was
really impressive extremely gory oh my
god yeah yeah but no it does it does
look fantastic that's my heart take one
of the things I liked most about it is
something that I'm not sure they've
talked about and I did I don't want to
go down shop but I won't talk offline
with you guys about there's something
that's in that video that I really like
I know is I want to talk about that I
can't remember if they've announced
tonight like the other day I apparently
announced features that were in a press
release a gun shy Biffle look at that
this is people we should just be aware
yeah well I hope that people especially
in light of this conversation which I
think has been incredibly well-rounded
well a great episode it's been a great
episode I'm not I have no idea what last
episode was I was at all me saying maybe
we
Oh No feels like you're answering that
by wearing a hat I'm surprised as you
won here surely that's the first episode
of the podcast that you can truly
experience the enjoy and have the joy of
opening for the first time with your
eyes closed and experience way to bring
you didn't bring pressure on you Troy
but if there's anything that you
anything that you really want people to
take before review start coming out the
floor is yours if there's anything you
would like to say obviously you can
literally just pause no I'm never gonna
opportunities it's it's it's certainly
nothing that I haven't said before but I
will always take an opportunity to
reiterate that by and large it is an
accepted objective fact that the
pedigree that Naughty Dog has as a
studio is unquestionable its
incontrovertible it is from people
within the industry and people outside
of the industry it is a place that
people look to to go we want to do it
this way they have whether you feel like
like accolades and awards are
meaningless or are meaningful they have
them in large supply and they have been
doing this for decades this is the
longest development cycle they've ever
had this is the most ambitious the
largest and scale scope everything that
they've ever done and to do so they grew
that level of talent skill and artisan
artisanal people to be able to make that
kind of game so you literally have
arguably the finest team ever assembled
to make a game and they spend six years
working on it painstakingly carefully
curating that game the odds are good the
odds are good that it's earned the
benefit of the doubt it is it is worthy
if nothing else of you plan
the game and then by all means form your
opinion but you owe it to yourself
[Laughter]
that's the marketing that's what that's
what the state of play show you some
gameplay sir my son's gonna come in to
me it was the best thing ever I'm just
just decipher real quick
I've said my thing but it's you you owe
it to if nothing else you owe it to
yourself and you owe it to the team to
just play the game and then say you hate
it or then say you don't agree with it
and then say it didn't need a sequel but
at least play it I will leave you on
this fact there's that this whole week
has been just just emotionally taxing
for a multitude of reasons and I've been
looking at the review code that I have
that Donnie dog was kind enough to send
to me and I'm I still have my eyes
closed I'm not wanting to open that box
because Alana I know how you feel
towards just like your your once you're
done with the game then I'm done with
the six years of development I'm done
it's it's like that game I can now say
that I've experienced it and right now
I'm in that schrödinger's place of I I
haven't yet reference every time I have
a blissful ignorance about what how I'll
feel after the end of it and everything
else and so I understand being hesitant
the today has been a great conversation
and and a great release and I'm grateful
for you three and I'm in for your
friendship to be able to have a platform
like this to discuss this but it is it
is the little things and and
I'll say one more thing I had someone
retouched me on social media and say
that the way that the state of the world
in the situation that she has gone
through she felt that the last of us had
had let her down because it's not what
she wanted it and needed it to be and I
understand that we because we're so
invested in in something we we want it
to be good and when there's a fear that
it's not going to be what we need it to
be to me is very reductive of the thing
because there's a thing there's there's
a the thing wants to be something itself
that exists outside of our opinion in
what we want it to be so that being able
to engage with her and normally I would
I would just ignore or just not engage
but I saw that there was a hurting heart
and so I reached out to her and I was
like I want to apologize that if
anything that I said that's not that was
not my intention and we had a great
discourse back and forth and it was it
was a beautiful thing to see happen when
someone who was vitriolic ly coming at
me
I was able to kind of wing chun and and
and and move that around and bring that
energy back to her and we had a great
conversation in response to love so
there was a great moment this has been a
great moment and last night just hanging
out with my dude he had spent a day at
the beach with Pam and he came back and
he was all sunkissed and his hair was
all just like crazy and I was putting
him down and it unprovoked he just looks
up to me I was just looking down at him
he says look some he goes I love you I
was like I'm done I'm done okay
everything is okay so it's it's looked
for those little moments whatever they
are they don't have to be a two-year-old
it's [ __ ] awesome in a genius and
loves the Beatles excellent but there
are there are all sorts that was just
right off screen now now now I can start
to fit stirring be the boy but there's
there's all there's there's it could be
a game it could be a book it could be a
conversation but there are
little points of light that exists
throughout our pedestrian world that
exists to just kind of keep you going
along and I hope that this podcast is
that for people this for me I had to I
had to I'm just really pleased you guys
know genuinely man like I'm just really
happy you guys have gone to say what you
want to say and gotten out there it's
it's amazing achievement like I am there
genuinely was like Mecca for me going to
know a dog for the first time still and
you know what's hilarious is I as a nerd
as someone who gets given a lot of free
t-shirts everywhere I go and wears those
t-shirts have no sense of fashion except
the shirt so if I want to have a good
day anywhere in the world
I wear the Naughty Dog t-shirt and
strangers will come up to me and I
either say say hello one talks to me
about about the games and I'm always
like yes I did I've designed not I kneel
but genuinely like just it's it's just
it's it's it's something awesome you
guys have put together I'm excited to
play thanks Ben I am too and I love your
Hunter s Thompson collection of shirts
so I think that jazzy well they're
meaningful enough to make it into the
logo iconic we all need we need to
update the logo now the whole facial I
think I'm gonna get rid of this thing
like tonight so I'll have the week-long
stubble next time if you haven't watched
let me please give a plug for Roger
Craig Smith one of the funniest people
in this industry and on this planet and
one of the most talented his stargazing
or whatever it's called photography is
brilliant he's now switched over to
doing birds but he did this like little
video
that's what a man does and it's it's
just a total bro thing on his on his
Instagram and I watch it countlessly and
it is [ __ ] hilarious what is his
Twitter handle okay it's just Roger
Craig Smith and it is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 down on his feed at time of
press and it is just but you say shaving
your face and please watch it please do
me the honor of watching it because it's
I'm intrigued I'm intrigued
all right everyone thank you for
listening I'm sure we will have more
doors conversations over the next few
weeks I'm still gonna try and use a
slate tale for you Austin and I really
did want to talk to you guys about what
I thought of psycho because I don't
understand I don't understand all right
that will stay there for another episode
but holy crap I can't wait my favorite
heist movie bye